hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round three of this
year's Tata still Challengers Edition it
is Thomas bertson versus yerushpehach
and I know what you guys are thinking
how come this is uh round three and
already we've seen three games by pehach
uh well he's he's always uh involved in
this uh these extremely interesting
games uh and this is one when you see it
you will of course realize why this is
the one I have chosen and uh lost in
round one to Max varmed I'm here he's
playing against his good friend Thomas
bertson I've seen an interview with Max
farmerdam where he says that he is uh
that he's very good friends with bertson
and that they sometimes have dinner and
lunch so uh obviously uh I imagine they
discussed what maybe uh Thomas will play
today against behatch also one of the
reasons why he chose that but we've seen
uh some uh games by Thomas on this
channel already and they are always uh
well just absolutely crazy games that
you guys will enjoy and this one is
pretty much exactly like that that and
it will feature a pause the video moment
that if you guys solve uh you you are
the greatest chess player ever so there
I've said it let's check it out uh
Thomas has the white pieces and he opens
with Ponte E4 yeah sorry about that
uh we have Pawn to E5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop the C4 going
for the Italian game and here Bishop to
C5 going for the Joker piano and now uh
you might be expecting something that
we've seen like a million times like
castles or C3 or D3 uh but no Thomas
goes for Pawn to B for the greatest move
there ever was and will be of course he
goes for the Evans Gambit uh and the
best way to play against the Evans
Gambit is to accept the Evans gamma the
bishop captures on B4 and it's also a
very exciting moment in the uh
tournament uh for real good because he
lost the first two games and he's a very
strong player he's 26-37 and now he's
playing against uh bertson who who is uh
25-15 and he's an international Masters
he still didn't didn't become a grand
master uh and this is not what you want
to have when you play in the tournament
you've lost the first two games and now
you you have to play against the Evans
Gambit so this is a very very hard to
imagine how how yarbrush was feeling
here but okay our best way to accept it
is by accepting we have Pawn to C3
Bishop to A5 and now Pawn to D4 so this
is the main line of the Evans Gambit uh
for those of you who still haven't seen
it I have made a video or rather a
tutorial on how to play the evidence
Gambit I will put a link to it first
link in the description below do check
it out it's closing in on a million
views so I imagine a lot of you guys are
interested in uh the Evans Gambit uh
once it hits that million I'm making a
part two with uh well some of the
improved lines that that have happened
over the years so here D4 we have D6 uh
e captures on D4 is by far the most
popular D6 also very much playable uh
Queen to B3 going after the F7 pawn and
now Queen to D7 you you don't want to
play Queen to E7 you kind of want to
leave that square for the knights uh and
now uh how do you continue this well you
just castle with Bishop to B6 this is
one of uh Black's main ideas how to
defend against the Evans Gambit you want
to clear the A5 Square for the Knight
attack the queen attack the bishop and
eliminate why it's a very strong light
Square Bishop so Knight beat the D2
there's really not all that much white
can do about this uh Knight to A5 and
now Queen to C2 and this is a very
standard position you will see pretty
much always uh when this line is played
and uh you will pretty much always see
Knight characters on C4 another option
that you could see is Pawn to F6 and
it's even one of the one of the uh
favorite options if you ask the engine
but it's very very tricky to play and it
was played in this game but uh here the
standard is just Knight captures and see
fortnite captures and queen the C6 here
you force some trades uh now for example
Knight captur say captures and B6 D
capras and E5 you even give up the E5
Pawn because you really want to survive
the game and develop let's say queen A4
now you try to trade queens and the game
continues white average trades probably
not Queen D3 uh and uh so on Knight to
F6 will uh black will of course try to
Castle and you can even go for some
crazy lines like Bishop to G5 uh give up
D for pawn queen to B5 check C6 Queen
captures and B6 and now if castles uh we
can even have something like this so
it's a everything is playable but this
is Black's uh best defense or maybe
consider Black's best defense but here
we have Pawn to F6 again it's not a new
move but now it allows Pawn to A4 and
now it's very different with the
inclusion of F6 you no longer have the
option of going Knight captures on C4 if
you try this now look at this Knight
captures on C4 and now if you try
something like um
uh Queen to see uh Queen to C6 it's not
all that great the queen can easily
defend for example Queen to D3 defends
the Knight and uh now A5 is a problem
you have to do something about this uh
if you deal with that then D5 is coming
and the queen is not a very comparable
uh on on C6 at all and how do you how do
you develop you can just develop the
Knight because A5 traps the bush if you
play A5 then Knight captures and now
you've ruined Black's Queen side
completely uh so white would be much
much better if not straight out winning
so instead after A4 we have the
immediate Knight the E7 and now comes uh
it's uh not a new move there there
actually is a position that reached this
in 2009 even Nigel short headed this
position against Anton philippov in
Kolkata India and the Nigel short lost
this with the white pieces and
Incredibly incredible as that sounds but
in that game night captures and C4 was
played but okay here we have Knight t7
and now uh sorry instead of 97 with
Knight to H6 but now Knight to E7 Bishop
back to A2 saving the bishop so now
Knight captures and C4 is no longer an
option and now there is a game where
Knight ate the C6 was played but here we
have Knight E to C6 uh by a year which
in it is now as of move 12 that we have
a completely new game and uh okay the
position is already incredibly
complicated but here it uh really
becomes complicated Bishop to A3 and now
the problem is uh going for this line
instead of just capturing the bishop and
trading everything like everyone does
here uh okay black might even be better
here but how are you ever dealing with
the bishop controlling this diagonal
it's just such an ugly position to have
uh even even if you know that it's
playable and even if you know that maybe
this is even stronger for black it's
just very hard so here e captures and D4
C captress Knight captures on D4 winning
upon but okay white um was giving up
that pawn either way Knight captures on
D4 and Bishop capture address we have
Rook 8 to D1 and now uh you have to be
again very very careful here you have to
either play Knight to C6 or something
like that but here Queen to E7 was
played spending another move with the
queen and really uh it's hard to
understand why maybe maybe his idea was
okay let's develop the light Square Bush
pen Castle Queen side although I I
really doubt that but here if uh Burton
finds a knight to F3 he will most likely
win the game very quickly he doesn't
find it he plays Pawn to E5 I'll just
show why Knight to F3 is incredibly
strong uh as now the bishop on D4 is
undefended and once you move that and
Bishop to E5 is the only good move you
have you will trade here you cannot
capture with the Deep one of course the
bishop and A3 is a monster you play F
captures and now Bishop to D5 uh and now
again what can black play yeah the
problem is if you play Pawn to C6
there's this incredible Bishop captures
and D6 now if Queen characters You're
Gonna Play Bishop F7 check and win the
queen so you can and play C6 but if you
don't play C6 what what's your move is
there a move you're gonna have to play
something like C5 but now you're never
castling Queen side you're never Castle
in King side it's just not uh you you
want to see like Queen D2 goes after the
Knight here of Queen D7 defending Now
Pawn to F or will open up the file for
The Rook as well uh black will not
survive this position so Knight to F3
here was deadly but uh here Thomas goes
for the uh for the even faster attack he
has some ideas here we have F characters
and E5 now Knight to F3 and now Knight
back to C6 quickly bringing this Knight
back and now we have Bishop to D5
another very tricky move that again asks
the question how do you develop here uh
problem is uh Bishop to E6 is the move
you have to play but it's uh it's
incredible uh to see this if Bishop if
Bishop E6 is just Bishop captures and
what's the idea here the idea is that
the King has to start running to G6 I
mean it's silly but look at this bishop
he's 6 Bishop captures and c6b captures
and now Queen captures on C6 with check
you will play King to F7 so now the
Rooks protect each other and now look at
this uh Rook capture Sun D4 what do you
play here E Capture Sun D4 now Knight to
E5 check it was important to eliminate
the bishop so the bishop doesn't control
the E5 Square you cannot capture because
you lose the queen so you have to go
King to F6 now Queen the F3 with check
and again you can't capture an E5 if you
capture an E5 Rook to E1 is mate in one
so you have to run away Kingdom uh or
rather a bishop to F5 is pretty much the
only move and now Rook D1 and if black
can survive this maybe it's possible The
Edge the engine says black black is
perfectly fine I mean the engine can
play anything uh but I mean looks looks
disgusting uh however it was the best
way to play this for black in the game
King the d8 was played uh but now this
brings other problems Rook after E1
mobilizing the other Rook as well uh
Queen to F6 now getting the queen out of
Harm's Way and now Bishop captures and
C6 B captures on C6 and now again a move
that is truly remarkable and was not
played in the game is Bishop captures on
D6 in the game Thomas went for uh Queen
captures and C6 right away but I will
just show you what a what a spectacle
Bishop captures on these sixes uh you're
wondering okay I can capture with the
pawn I can capture with the queen what's
the idea if Queen captures uh Knight
captures an E5 and the black falls apart
uh the thread is Knight F7 check which
will uh Fork the king the queen and the
Rook so A beautiful Monster Royal fork
and if Rook to f8 then there's uh the
even stronger Knight captures than C6
check and now Rook captures on D4 is
Just Deadly King these seven real
captors on D4 uh that's it black resign
so what you would have to do after this
bishop capture some D6 move is captured
with the c Pawn but this makes all the
difference now you're gonna play Knight
captures on D4 and the Knight cannot be
captured if you capture the Knight and
then Queen captures on C6 attacks the
rook and once you play Rook B8 there's
the spectacular Rook to C1 and there is
no defense against the queen to C7 uh if
you play Rook to B7 then Queen captures
and C8 if you try to defend with the
black queen then you uh sorry then you
no longer guard the D6 spawned in just
Queen captures and D6 is deadly uh this
is instant resigns so uh Bishop captures
and D6 here would have finished the game
on the spot however Queen captures on C6
was played which is still fine for white
it's not just not as deadly because does
not have to Rook to B8 look at this Rook
the C1 was played but now the same idea
that we we just tried no longer works
because now after Knight captures on D4
you can capture and after Rook to C1
Rook to B7 and the C Pawn is here you
haven't played Bishop captures capture
so the bishop and C8 would hang and here
uh black would survive so instead Rook
the C1 was played immediately trying to
go after the C7 pawn and the black is
still okay with Rook to B7 however uh I
mean you have to calculate so many lines
here uh Bishop to B6 was played and this
is an error and uh Thomas takes
advantage of it he plays Knight captures
on E5 uh point is that well there's
really no good move if you capture the
Knight and while you can do this or you
can just play Rook e to D1 check and
there's no good way to defend this all
of the squares are taken from the black
king so the black king cannot defend you
have to play Bishop to D4 but then just
Rook captures and D4 with check and
after captures on D4 now the C7 Pawn is
no longer defended Queen captures on C7
King to E8 Rook D1 with check and that's
pretty much it you you can capture here
but the black king will get checkmated
very quickly however after Knight
captures an E5 of course D captures and
E5 wasn't played Rook to E8 was played
and now uh well now the things get very
very interesting now after Rook to E8
there is a winning move for white but
it's so spectacular and this is the move
I was talking about at the beginning of
the video If you find this move then uh
you are I don't know like you you you
you have uh you if you if you are not
already 2500 or 2600 you definitely have
potential to be uh a a a grand master uh
so feel free to pause the video and
really try your best to spot the winning
move here there's only one and it's it
will blow your mind if you find it
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations uh on spotting
this uh incredible idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Pawn to A5 that's the move that wins
the game for white incredible as it is
uh the problem is uh what is black to do
with the bishop uh if you move the
bishop let's say you play Bishop
captures in F2 because this is always an
option it's just that it does nothing
for black but it's very interesting in
this line if Bishop captures an F2 you
will just move the king king to H1 and
now okay uh you have to do something now
this is being threatened so you have to
play Rook to E7 but now Bishop captures
and D6 works again and if Queen captures
on D6 then you have this Knight to F7
check beautiful now if Rook characters
then Rook the E8 is Checkmate so you
cannot play that but uh it's your only
move so you have to recaptures an F7
Rook to d8 will be Checkmate so Queen
will not be able to capture Bishop you
will have to play C captures on D6 but
now again look at this Knight to F7
check absolutely spectacular again if
Rook captures a rook to E8 is Checkmate
but okay here you can capture with the
queen queen captures um on F7 and now
Queen captures on D6 with check Rook to
D7 and now you have Queen captures on B8
uh the threat remains Queen captures and
C8 is coming and there's no good way to
deal with this you will have to play
Bishop capture Sunny one Queen capture
Sun C8 and one's King to E7 is played
sorry Rook captures anyone with check
and that's pretty much it you will soon
win The Rook or whatever you play if
King here then Rook to F1 with check
doesn't really matter if King here then
wrote the D1 with checking E6 and now
you nicely connect with the rook and
that's it here you resign just captures
and you are up a full piece uh so that's
the problem here uh with A5 if Bishop
captures on F2 is played Queen captures
and F2 also does nothing uh uh it's uh
well you could play Queen captures here
uh King to H1 but still nothing is being
threatened and uh your Bishop is still
hanging so now you could play Rook
captures on E5 but now Rook captures on
E5 and again this is in possible if D
captures an E5 then a captures on B6 uh
Queen characters on C7 is being
threatened and now after Queen captures
and B6 there's the spectacular Rook to
D1 check and the King has no squares uh
if you play Bishop Bishop to D7 you will
just capture that bishop and if you
block with the queen then Rook
eliminates Queen with check and one C
captures on D4 is played uh again
anything wins here even the the
spectacular Bishop the E7 can be played
with check it's a forced capture
captures captures and now you will also
pick up the rook and easy win for white
so that's what happens with A5 if you
capture an F2 so you can't capture any
F2 but can you capture an A5 this gets
even trickier and this is why the A5
move is so crazy if you play Bishop
captures on A5 uh look at this again
Bishop captures on D6 but now there's a
very big difference
regarding to what happened in the actual
game c captures on D6 Knight the F7 with
check opening up an attack on that Rook
here so Queen characters on F7 but now
you no longer defend the pawn queen
captures on D6 and now uh Queen to D7
you block check and now uh after this uh
block you will play Rook capture 78 with
check first king captures only move and
now Queen captures and B8 and now the
problem is uh okay the bishop here is
hanging again once you capture that
you're completely winning King to d8 and
now Queen to F4 and this is all forced
and this is the only way to play this
queen to f8 is being threatened which
will force uh Queen T8 followed by Rook
captures and see it checking captures
and then Queen will capture Queen so
here your only defense will be Queen to
F5 and now only now after Queen to F5
you understand the point of Pawn to A5
the point of A5 with the put the black
Bishop on A5 because now you can just
trade queens and after Bishop captures
you uh Fork the two Bishops that's
that's the point of A5 believe it or not
and that's it once you move either
Bishop you will just capture another one
and now you have a completely winning
end game so that's why I said after this
rooked Rook d8 move if any of you find
A5 by pausing the video
I mean I I'm I'm speechless but it was
not found in the game in the game Thomas
went for Bishop captures on D6 right
away and it seems like it's the same but
the problem is black has that very nasty
defense uh and the the uh the bishop
will be on B6 and not an A5 I mean a
very scary stuff C captures on D6 now
Knight to F7 check Queen captures on F7
Queen captures on D6 everything the same
like we've discussed Queen to D7 and now
Rook captures 98 Queen uh King cap or 78
only move and now Queen captures and B8
but now okay uh the uh the bishop is
still hanging so King to d8 and now we
have Queen to F4 again going for this
tricky Queen to f8 maneuver that we've
just shown but now Queen to F5 and this
is now a proper defensive idea for black
because now you don't have Queen
captures Bishop captures and The Rook
the C5 as the bishop is here and there's
really nothing to try here your queen is
hanging Queen to G3 you cannot really
trade The Rook against the bishop pair
will not Prevail G6 and now Pawn to A5
well now he finds it but it's a few
moves too late uh and it's uh it's an
attempted one less trick now if Queen
captures an A5 Queen to D6 check wins
the game for white because you have to
remove the defender of the bishop but
after A5 Bishop captures an A5 was
played and now Queen to D6 with check
Bishop to B7 and queen to B8 with check
we have King to E7 and queen captures an
A7 but now just Queen to D5 centralizing
the queen everything is nicely defended
there's no way to add more pressure and
uh here Thomas said all right uh I mean
there's nothing more to be done here
Queen to C5 check he offered a draw and
he was in this position on move 36 that
the players agree to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here once the
Queens get traded off it's a rook
against two Bishops also white has three
pawns and black S2 so uh no one is the
anyone here from this position so truly
remarkable after Queen C5 check they
they agree to a draw and this position
after Rook to E8 the Whitehead winning
ideas throughout the entire game but
this one this A5 move such such a
spectacular position now this uh if if
you know books were still being printed
the the this this belongs in every chess
book on uh on the Italian game and
specifically on the Evans Gambit uh but
yeah truly incredible stuff uh I'm
always uh incredibly joyful when someone
goes for the Evans Gambit in a classical
game so a big congratulations to Thomas
bertson on that but also big
congratulations
on Surviving
um uh and Evans Gambit game with the
black pieces against such a such a
formidable opponent uh so it's really
spectacular like I said if you if you
want to improve your Evans Gambit to do
study it I also have a video on it will
be the first link in the description
below if you still haven't checked it
out some fun lines to explore there so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it once again huge
congratulations to everyone who spotted
the A5 here you are you are truly a
grand master material I would like to
thank doitran ravishing reptiles YouTube
safeshotter.org server
shelter.orgban brunism out water for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata steel boat master and Challengers
until it finishes thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day